welcome back to new rockstars i'm eric
voss and the suicide squad directed by
james gunn
was one of the most exciting things to
come out of dc's fandom event
a sequel slash reboot but also neither
to the 2016 film with a huge cast
playing an
insane crew of misfit toys showcased in
a behind the scenes teaser i am gonna
comb through this footage frame by frame
to point out the visual details and
easter eggs that you need to know about
to explain what this movie
is the plot the characters the villain
who if any of them will make it out
alive
and how we are seeing john cena since
he's supposed to be invisible
spoiler warning in case any of my
predictions end up being right i have
gotten
kind of good at finding things that
filmmakers are like oh [ __ ] i didn't
mean for that to be in the trailer and
before i continue i am super excited to
announce
that oomaze is offering you the chance
to win a 20
000 dream pc taxes and shipping are
included and even better every donation
benefits a great cause all you gotta do
is go to omaze.com
rockstars and enter your chance to win
okay this behind the scenes teaser
is an insane scatter shot of film
footage candid set moments
cast photo shoots and more it doesn't
really have that short film narrative
that traditional trailers do
so here's what i'm gonna do i'm gonna
boil this down to the big details that
are hard to catch
and then like reassemble the available
footage to answer your big questions
first
how does this connect to the previous
suicide squad so james gunn is avoiding
calling this film a sequel because it's
not really a continuation of the plot in
the world as it was left from the first
film
but rather a sequel to the type of
suicide missions in john osterman's
suicide squad comics in the late 80s but
this movie is set in the continuity of
the dc extended universe with margot
robbie's harley quinn
viola davis amanda waller joel
kinnaman's rick flagg and jai courtney's
captain boomerang returning for this
new mission will smith's deadshot still
exist in this universe but the actor
elected not to return for this film but
joining those four will be a cast of
newcomers
characters ranging in levels of fame and
obscurity from the roster of dc villains
interest elba is confirmed to play
bloodsport robert dubois
a mercenary who previously shot superman
with a kryptonite bullet
john cena blaze peacemaker
aka christopher smith a kind of pacifist
who in the comics uses non-lethal
weapons and methods but in this movie
finds a way to seek peace by
killing people cena described his
character as a douchey captain america
lula borg plays javelin a german athlete
and former green lantern foe who uses a
yeah you know pete davidson plays
blackguard aka richard dick
hertz yeah who's kind of an idiot with
powerful armor from the booster gold
comics yondu actor michael rooker is
playing savant
brian durlin a cyber criminal and
martial artist enemy to the birds of
prey turned kind of disloyal
jerk in recent suicide squad comics
nathan fillion is a character named
tdk which we're thinking might stand for
the detachable kid
based on arm fall-off boy whose arms
plorp off and then can be used as
weapons
his logo shows a skull with two severed
arms
and early in this behind the scenes
footage there's a quick flash of
storyboard previous visuals
where you can see his detached arms flew
the borg also hinted at this
everyone is exploding genitals heads
arms legs
i am so excited similarly bizarre is
david dasmalchian as
polkadot man abner krill kind of a minor
batman villain who
flings the polka dots off to suit his
weapons there's a very quick shot in the
trailer showing those polka dots
freakishly bulging out of his skin like
goiters
suggesting that he might have to like
squeeze these out of his flesh
daniella melchior is ratcatcher 2 a
female version of the batman villain
ratcatcher a former exterminator who can
communicate with
and control an army of rats comedian
steve agee plays
king shark a villain to superboy and the
cw flash
this guy looks awesome we see him eating
the dude in the trailer there is some
debate over whether aj is doing the
mocap
and the voice or just the mocap but i'm
pretty sure he's doing both we'll talk
more about this in a bit peter capaldi
is the thinker
a firestorm villain also in the cw flash
series but here he has more
comic accurate nodes on his head he's
super smart he's got telepathy
telekinesis then meiling ong is mong gao
an alien warrior with super agility twin
sister to mongol the younger and it's
pretty nuts that she's in this
because it suggests aliens other than
kryptonians exist
in this universe sure why not but also
might tell us something about this
movie's big twist
alice braga plays seoul surya who i'm
guessing is a female version of juan
surea from the dc comics whose hands
have been replaced with cybernetic
nanite implants that can be used to like
crack open doors or jailbreak stuff
and then of course sean gunn who
mocapped as rocket in the marvel films
he is now suiting back up in that mocap
suit as weasel
god bless this man now throughout this
teaser cast and crew have made it clear
the number of these people will die
don't get too attached
so which one should we get attached to
and what are they trying to do that's
putting them in so much danger what's
the stateside mission
well tomorrow's episode of rogue theory
is going to go into some alternate ideas
of what the mission could be but here's
what i think it is two more cast members
that i did not mention are joaquin casio
who's playing
major general matteo suarez and juan
diego boto as presidente general
silvio luna i think you can briefly see
suarez standing on a jeep
fleeing a set at this tropical fortress
to get a much better fully rendered shot
of as well
where the top of that tower has been
badly damaged leaving rubble down below
this seems like the compound that the
suicide squad is trying to break into
they shot this movie in panama and
fighting with or alongside the squad
appear to be south american soldiers
with patches of a flag colored red
yellow and blue now the south american
countries venezuela ecuador colombia
feature those same colors on their flags
but all three of those countries order
them
yellow then blue then red either way i
think what we're looking at is a
fictional south american country in the
midst of a military coup
or civil war some kind of change of
power a conflict between the political
leader
luna and the military commander suarez
and the us government
is sending in the suicide squad to
intervene i think to help suarez
take control from presidente luna who
has
lost it also notice how in all the
trailer footage for the most part the
cast
seems to be split up into two teams i
think this is intentional and i think
the fandom panel playing that game with
two teams is a clue to that but before
we continue thanks to omaze for
sponsoring this video
enter for your chance to win twenty
thousand dollars to build your ultimate
dream pc while supporting a great
charity by going to omaze.com
rockstars and using the code rockstars
50 for 50 additional entries
omaze's model democracizes traditional
auction giving by
offering everyone the chance to have a
once in a lifetime experience that also
benefits a charity
through the omaze platform people from
more than 180 countries have made
donations that support
over 350 charities raising more money
than traditional methods they've given
over 130 million dollars to charity and
their goal is to raise a billion dollars
in a single year
on a maze you can enter to win a tesla
or a vacation in new zealand or
have a virtual play date with big bird
while supporting charities like
make-a-wish and the boys and girls club
omaze is offering you the chance to win
an
ultimate dream pc taxes and shipping are
included in even better every donation
but if it's a great cause
gamers outreach a charity that works
with the gaming community to provide
recreation for kids in hospitals miranda
l from laguna niguel california recently
won
an ultimate dream pc so for your chance
to be like miranda l
and win the ultimate dream pc go to
omaze.com rockstars and enter code
rockstars50 for
50 additional entries every donation
supports gamer's outreach so hurry up
that's omaze.com
rockstars go there donate and good luck
the first group i'm going to call
team flag not just because they're all
lined up marching in front of a huge ass
flag but also because they appear to be
led by rick flagg
that team includes savant tdk captain
boomerang
javelin mongal blackguard and weasel
yeah throughout this footage aside from
the full cast photo shoots you rarely
see any of the characters from team flag
outside of their recruitment from prison
or headed off toward the mission or in
the very first part of that mission that
nighttime storming to the beach
and then we rarely or never see those
characters get much further than that
from this footage
by contrast the characters who as of
right now are seeing a lot more action
tend to be shown grouped together in
another team and i hate to say it it
does contain the more famous movie stars
or weirder groot style misfits who we
would want to see more throughout the
mission i'm talking about bloodsport
peacemaker harley quinn king shark the
thinker polkadot man
ratcatcher 2 maybe also solceria i am
calling this group
team waller after the opposing team
captain from the fandome panel there's
also a shot of waller recruiting
peacemaker and bloodsport from prison
and a shot of her with steve aegee who's
not king shark yet
i believe rick flagg will lead the first
wave of his assembled task force x
containing a bunch of these one note
oddballs
many of whom get immediately killed off
or incapacitated which then requires
waller to send in the backup team
to rescue the others and finish a job
notice how there's a shot of blackguard
appearing to surrender right away on the
beach
and then javelin's javelin can be seen
throughout the footage later carried by
harley quinn
now a few from this first team might
survive like rick flagg can later be
seen sparring with peacemaker
maybe boomerang maybe mon gal who can be
seen with harley but i'm just saying
don't be surprised if black guard
javelin savant tdk
weasel gets slip knotted early but why
would teen flag lose so badly what
secret weapon did el presidente general
luna unleash on this first wave okay if
you look closely in the opening shots of
this teaser
there is a literal blank if you miss it
frame of tanks filled with some bubbling
red liquid
a lab presumably conducting research on
some kind of organic matter now back to
steve age part of the reason some people
think he won't be doing the voice of
king shark
is a report that taika waititi will be
playing a still
unknown surprise voice over role for the
film but i don't think about tta is
voicing king shark aeg is a hilarious
vocal performer they hired him for a
reason instead i think watiti's iconic
voice will be in a role that's even more
key to this plot okay you're gonna think
i'm crazy but i want you to look very
closely at this shot of polka dot man
early in the trailer
among the soldiers in the background on
the far left of frame there is one that
is incapacitated with something
bright pink with a blue stripe latched
onto that soldier's face
recently there was another report saying
that the dc villain
starro will play a role in this suicide
squad film
so starro the conqueror was the first
villain faced by the justice league of
america it's a
starfish starfish-like extraterrestrial
that came to earth and empowered three
starfish one of which
took over a small seaside town in rhode
island the starfish
latch onto the face and controlled the
mind of the host actually rick and morty
riders recently cited starro as the
inspiration for the glorzo facehuggers
and
watiti having voiced glooty on rick and
morty an alien aiming to conquer earth
via the love finders relationship app
he would be perfect as the voice of
starro again i'm not making this up we
have
proof in the footage of some kind of
starfish looking thing with the same
color scheme as starro latched onto a
soldier's face
there are a bunch of shots of the b team
in this office building in this town
where some explosion appears to lead
this
office getting flooded it's an office
building higher than sea level why is it
filled with water well i think that
explosion could be
bursting a tank filled with those
starfish which
is what the polka dot man could be
flinging his polka dots
at so i think some starro starfish have
invested this seaside south american
base
set up residency with tanks and labs to
incubate more of those offspring and
taking control of el presidente general
luna whose
name in spanish translates to moon maybe
a reference reflecting these things
arrival from space necessitating suarez
to attempt a coup but fails and then
flag comes in to lead one suicide squad
without knowing what they're really
dealing with so they fail too
maybe with some of them getting
starrowed like it'd be pretty hilarious
if dick hurt scott starroad in a way
that lives up to his name
then in that group mongal as the one
extraterrestrial of that team
recognizes that [ __ ] right away and
knows to stay back so then flag has to
begrudgingly radioed to waller for
backup and waller sends in
the suicide squad including experts in
mind control
and in pest control and yeah a [ __ ]
sea creature
their goal to wreck the stars yeah i
know what you're thinking parasitic
alien starfish in a south american
military coup it's a bit of a bonkers
plot but
i also think it is perfectly in line
with james gunn's creativity and
honestly i hope it's the tip of the
iceberg with how insane this movie gets
look there is still more to talk about
from the reveals at dc fandom including
news about this insane flashpoint movie
in the works to get our coverage right
away when it comes out
subscribe to this channel and hit that
notification bell and for more personal
takes on all this stuff new rockstars
has a super fun discord community that
we love it's for patrons of all tiers
even one dollar a month just go to
patreon.com new rockstars follow me on
instagram eaboss follow new rockstars
and again for a chance to win a 20 000
dream pc and benefit a great cause go to
omaze.com rockstars and enter for your
chance to win
thanks for watching bye
[Music]
you